we're here to talk more about each
candidate's performances to buy a
sellwood conservative mp and supporter
of penny mordent thank you so much for
talking to us this morning so how do you
think penny morden did in that debate
well i think the big takeaway for me was
just those issues on trust uh it was
just astonishing i mean i think we knew
it anyway that the
the trust has erosion with the british
people and the public and with the
conservative party in particular and i
very much like the idea of penny
speaking about not just a leader but
that we are actually selecting a prime
minister and if we want to continue
being uh having a prime minister in the
conservative party we need to be looking
to the next general election penny spoke
about the ship uh not just the captain
and i think that's where we've gone awry
with
boris johnson again on that trust issue
all the the contestants up there very
concerned about the erosion of trust and
what happened with boris johnson i felt
like you've indicated myself because i
came out back in february and said this
is not our our guy this is not who
should be leading uh the country so this
has been a reality check for everybody
but uh i also think it's the first
debate we've got another one on sunday
another one on monday
as well and we'll be able to go into
these issues a bit more taxation as you
were mentioning as well benny morton
focusing on growth making sure that we
actually make the cake bigger not just
you know the tax and spend issues uh of
the past we've got to get through the
next couple of years which can be very
tricky is inflation spikes and then
comes back uh back down again so i think
she did a it was a solid performance
from from penny but we've got uh a
couple more debates to go
she didn't really give she wasn't very
substantive should we say on tax policy
do you think in general she actually has
enough substance in the long run to be
the prime minister if at this stage she
can't give us specific policies
well she did give specific policies on
uh growth there's a a focus on uh
reducing the fuel uh price of fuel
straight away on increasing tax
thresholds these would be done
immediately but she also gave him to say
that and i think this will apply to any
leader that whoever then comes in is
going to have to probably have an
emergency budget uh in the autumn to
look at where we go
as a nation the cost of living crisis is
serious we need to look at our fiscal
policies what we can do to greater
support the british
people and it's not going to be simply
done by borrowing huge sums of money
which is going to cause more problems in
the longer term
but can you understand the people
watching last night looked looked penny
more than heard what she said and
thought this is being very vague it's
just vague comments how can we actually
now vote for vague comments
well you won't be voting for vague
comments at all you've been voting for
manifestos don't forget this is about
there were three audiences here that
were watching this not just mps party
members the nation as well uh there will
be plenty of opportunity to spell out
not just an economic policy but that on
the nhs
as well that was the other the third big
question that came up is how we're going
to pay for this
it was a great reality check i think for
our party to face the british people and
hear directly what needs to happen
on defense spending in particular i know
this is something that you're keen on
very vague as well she said she'd keep
2.5 but there may be an uptick i mean do
you think
that she should be as specific as others
of being and say yes 3 that's what we're
going for
well
you're absolutely right it didn't come
up last night britain's place in the
world then one of the things that
attracts me about penny morden is the
fact that it should be determined to
make sure that we do have a greater
voice and more coordinated voice on the
international stage there's an absence
of leadership in europe at the moment in
focusing on what do we do with ukraine
we're doing enough to make sure they
don't lose we're not enough to make sure
they win we don't have a policy on
russia what i understand and have got
confirmed from the penny board camp
is that we will be looking at
the state of our armed forces and making
sure that they have the competence to
meet the challenging threats i make it
very clear to all candidates i know
penny understands this the next 10 years
is going to be very very difficult
indeed security wise we are going to
have to spend more on defense you can
throw these numbers out like 2.5 percent
but ultimately you need to look at what
our capabilities are right now the
shortfalls particularly uh in uh
stockpiles of weapon systems and
ammunition we're going to have to review
that and that will have to happen
probably in the autumn as well just um
to end with briefly i want to talk to
you about this blue on blue fighting and
in particular one area and there has
been a lot of criticism about penny
mordant being a naval reservist i've
i've actually heard it being called
camouflage camouflage cosplay tom huden
heart an army reservist he has not
suffered the same
what do you think about that
i'm just really sorry that uh again
we're stooping to some of those levels
that you
see i mean i've been very careful even
in this interview absolutely i'm
supporting penny morden but i have huge
respect for my other uh colleagues as
well at the other flip side of this we
need to rally round the next prime
minister and make sure that we can show
the british people that we've learned
the lessons on discipline on focus on
vision of where we want to take the
nation and when we do these sort of
things and this blue on blue it actually
takes us the other way it actually
reduces our standing
within the british people as well penny
more than served continues to serve her
country uh from a uh military capacity
and she wants to do that now on the
national stage as well let's keep this
campaign positive let's focus on what
british people actually need rather than
actually taking chunks out of each other
okay mr wood thanks a lot for talking to
us
thank you